a brand new continent has emerged in the
middle of the pacific ocean
a process that would typically take
millions of years
happened overnight
how would this disrupt the earth's
fragile geography
how would global superpowers deal with a
new strategic territory up for grabs
and would this new land mass be good for
humanity or would it have
terrible consequences
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a new continent formed
tomorrow
[Music]
our planet didn't always have the
continents you know and love
four billion years ago as tectonic
plates underneath the earth's surface
slid around
the land on their edges started to rise
these scattered chunks collided over
billions of years until they formed the
first supercontinent called rodinia
then the land continued to break apart
and come back together
another supercontinent pangaea was
formed
and around 200 million years ago pangaea
began to break apart into the continents
you know today all these changes
happened over millions of years but if a
new continent suddenly emerged in less
than 24 hours
how would this disrupt your day-to-day
life
you might be surprised to learn that
1067 meters under the south pacific
is the hidden continent of zealandia
even though ze landia isn't officially
recognized as an eighth continent it's
nearly 70 percent as large as australia
and 5.2 million square kilometers
but
only six percent of this continent sits
above sea level
for a new land mass to be considered a
continent it would need to have a
surface area similar to zealandia and it
would need to be a large continuous
discrete mass of land ideally separated
by an expanse of water
the pacific ocean has an average depth
of 4 000 meters so
a significant volume of rock would need
to be forced upward to shape a new
continent
the plates in this region would shift
and collide with an incredible amount of
violence
there would be massive earthquakes and
volcanic eruptions as the land built up
the sudden increase in land volume would
have a dramatic impact on the already
rising sea levels
current estimates put the world on track
for sea levels to rise by two and a half
meters by the year 2100
this would only be a drop in the bucket
compared to what you would experience if
a new continent emerged overnight
a continent with the surface area of
zealandia would instantly make sea
levels rise 40 meters overnight
massive flooding would occur all over
the globe
low-lying nations such as bangladesh
senegal and the netherlands would
disappear
and this would be just the beginning
a new continent in the middle of the
pacific would cause massive disruptions
to the ocean's currents
these currents play an essential role in
driving our weather systems
they store solar radiation and move heat
and moisture around the planet
this would primarily impact the north
pacific subtropical gyre
this is the large system of swirling
ocean currents
one of the largest biomes on earth it is
home to many species of marine animals a
new continent would disrupt the roots
many of these animals travel
the formation of a new continent would
also have serious geopolitical
ramifications
oceans are technically viewed as
international zones
that means no one country has
jurisdiction over them
if a continent appeared within 22
kilometers of a country's coastline
that country could make a legitimate
claim to ownership
but with all the tectonic violence
needed to create this land
most countries would probably not want
any part of it
but if this new continent emerged in the
middle of the pacific ocean
it would be more challenging to decide
who owns it
there would be a huge international
debate that could create high tension
among powerful nations
the united nations the essential
governing body over the oceans would
have to oversee this significant
political event
and if you were looking to move to this
very new land
it would need to be habitable first
the continent would emerge from the sea
completely barren it would be all rock
with no soil and no source of fresh
water
it could become a popular tourism area
or
even a radical solution for storing
toxic waste
we live in a highly connected world
where even small incremental changes can
lead to disaster
the formation of a continent this big
would be devastating for us
and the earth's ecosystems
you know maybe we'd have been better off
if the supercontinent pangaea never
broke apart
but
that's a story
for another
what if
you